and now it's time for bombing reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review waiters this is this
guy Corbin the statue would critique
with you like a more high pitched in
Kinnison who dreams of owning his own
nation I own my own nation once or at
least I marked him with my urine so he
plans on taking over the nation of
Molossia it's in third place nobody has
a president his name is Kevin bad boy
that's a weird name isn't it sounds like
a sheep Oh is there some talk show I'm
given
so the distensible Critic gets all these
buddies together and they rush towards
then they shine but unfortunately he has
a very thick build me first for the
money I paid to get on the set I told
you that teeth will be put to good use
and in this town were pretty is dressed
up like a giant red pincushion I paid
over the country mr. bad about my
friends well can we still look at each
er great yeah something is Samson the
critic takes a role in molasses except
he calls a taxi you know you don't say
the in situ do I'll let you do this some
of you do that why not I just complain
and watch TV
settling those political commentators
any restriction sort of looks like that
one politician the dim one who always
wants attention
well the cleavage so everybody's the way
the country's being prodded and
something's can call that cinema snob
it's gonna do something about it I don't
like the way this country's being wrong
I want you to stop do you stop talking
about technical said no do you manage
for baggage from Castilla so the descent
is cement factory
say no who also happens to be Spoony
which is weird
I've seen them to each other words quick
cameo bored jeans explaining how the
plague risk which is more exciting than
actually playing risk after a car comes
up with a brilliant foolproof strategy
true critic fighting over who should be
in charge by who can do the best thing I
can do the best Jack Nichols I can do
the best turn Thomas said to Christ
appears why from the gravy Sami Christ I
was a zombie Christ once hey was there
so Santa crazily what some of the people
in his life stabbing okie turn this -
from a critic to the nation back to
Kevin bass everybody walks away looking
me sad he shoots the narrator who sounds
like Makos British cousin Bernie so he
can see it was a really great two-year
anniversary and where that guy with the
glasses dad can hope to make many more
in the future
but there's only one way we can make
that happen
come on J come on otherwise he hasn't
made a smaller country next year I hear
they're taking over